OK, we're live.
You are in for an experience.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome.
Thank you for joining us.
I'm really glad to be part of--
--this evening's special Q&A.
--of Boys State.
Boys State.
It's a remarkable documentary.
It won the US Grand Jury prize
at the 2020 Sundance Film
Festival.
It's an incredible film.
A riveting documentary.
I thought it was fascinating.
I loved it.
I was weeping by the end.
This film is fantastic.
Each year, hundreds of students
gather for a 10 day retreat
to learn about
electoral politics
at the local and state level.
This is a place where people
from different points of view,
and different political leanings
get together and talk politics.
The Boys State
program could really
show us what the country
was feeling and expressing,
the health of our democracy, and
how young people will hopefully
help lead us forward.
After seeing the film,
I'm really excited.
I'm so excited.
I'm so thrilled.
--to bring on Amanda
McBaine and Jesse
Moss-- the filmmakers
behind Boys State
--and also Robert MacDougall,
Stephen Garza, Rene Otero,
and Ben Feinstein.
What do you think you learned
at Boys State about how
politics actually works?
Politics is hard.
[LAUGHTER]
People in this country are
starved for good leadership.
If you look at the other
side only as the enemy,
it doesn't leave any room
to actually work together.
This is such a wild moment for
this movie to be coming out.
Young people engaging in
conversation and debate,
during a moment when our
democracy needs this.
It's so timely.
It really does hold up a
mirror to the divisions
that we face as a country.
Get yourselves ready for
a turbulent election.
What are some of the
themes that you're
hoping arise, from the film,
that perhaps can inform us
to a better state of politics?
Most people, in the
end, want what's
best for their state
and their country,
and the only difference
is in the ways
we have of getting there.
We might have different
political views,
we might come from different
cities or backgrounds.
At the end of the day,
we're all Americans,
and we will have to share
this country that we live in.
What sort of change do you
want to see in the future?
It is up to us as a nation
to engage civically,
beyond just going
out to the polls.
We can't stand on the sidelines
and expect these problems
in our society to
fix themselves.
You can bring people together.
You can bring together
those two sides,
have those conversations,
reach across the aisle,
shake that hand.
Maybe our generation
could be the ones
to end that gridlock
of partisanship.
I'm optimistic, because so are
360 million other Americans.
But we do have an
opportunity to change
the direction of this country.
We need to all work together.
It's critically important.
Democracy is not
a spectator sport.
Got to get off the sidelines.
Democracy is not to
be taken for granted.
Democracy is fragile.
Something that has
to be defended,
preserved, and protected.
It is up to us to keep it.
Young people, now more than
ever, involved in politics,
and interested.
And hoping that
this film kind of
motivates them to
keep pushing, and push
for fighting the good fight.